-Republicans, from Ron DeSantis
to Donald Trump
are lying about masks
and trying to rewrite history,
when it comes
to their negligent handling
of the coronavirus pandemic.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
The current Republican Party
is still very much
Donald Trump's Republican Party,
as evidenced by the fact that
aspiring Republican candidates
are all desperate to mimic him
and lavish praise on him.
The most popular
Republican politicians
among Republican voters,
the ones who are angling
to be president,
aren't the ones
who have actually done
a competent job on COVID.
They're the ones desperately
trying to imitate Trump
and repeat his disastrous
COVID response,
like Texas Senator Ted Cruz,
whose state is experiencing
a major surge in COVID cases,
with hospitals filling up
and ICU beds scarce,
thanks, in part, to the lack
of mitigation efforts
and low vaccination rates.
And, yet, even amid
all that needless suffering,
Cruz said last week that he's
against mandates of any kind.
-My view is very simple.
There should be no mandates,
zero,
concerning COVID.
That means no mask mandates,
regardless of your
vaccination status.
That means no vaccine mandates.
That means no vaccine passports.
And I've introduced legislation,
a bill to ban vaccine passports;
this week, I'm introducing
a bill to ban vaccine mandates;
and, this week, I'm introducing
a bill to end mask mandates.
-[ As Cruz ]
That's right -- no mandates.
No mask mandates.
No vaccine mandates.
And, if I want to show up
to Long John Silver's
without a shirt and shoes,
then that's my right
as an American,
under Section 57, Article Z,
of the Constitution.
This is exactly what happened
to Ethan Allen
at Fort Ticonderoga.
The British wouldn't let him sit
without putting on a shirt,
and that's why he started
making his own furniture.
[ Laughter ]
You know, sometimes when you
disagree with someone,
you can at least understand
their point of view,
but I just can't access
the frame of mind
of a person who thinks wearing
a piece of cloth over your face
while you're shopping
for toilet paper at Costco
is some "Give me liberty
or give me death" moment.
You think the founding fathers
would've been anti-mask?
Those guys were powdered wigs
and Capri pants indoors in July.
They [bleep] loved
being uncomfortable.
[ Laughter ]
You got Republicans
like Madison Cawthorn
saying he won't "bend the knee"
and Rand Paul saying
"They can't arrest us all."
If you guys are so desperate
to pretend you're
founding fathers,
just become reenactors.
I see them in the park
once in a while.
They seem like
they're having a good time.
Of course,
there's always one dude
who accidentally
leaves his ringer on
and disrupts the whole flow.
[ English accent ]
By orders of the crown,
I hereby declare you a traitor
and sentence you to --
Oh.
Hold on. My Apple.
It's my Apple Watch
is ringing.
Hold on.
Honey?
What do you mean, they're
out of matcha smoothies?
Well, do they have flaxseed?
Well, what about spirulina?
What the hell else am I supposed
to get my B vit--
You know what?
Listen, I got to go.
Everybody's yelling,
"Witchcraft" at me
and Dave just got hit
by a Frisbee golfer.
[ Laughter ]
And that's today's
Republican Party.
For a year and a half, we've
been battling a deadly virus
to save as many lives
as possible
and their main priority is
standing in the way
and making it harder.
Like Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis,
whose state has been
breaking records
for new cases
and hospitalizations
and, yet, DeSantis is not only
against masks personally,
he's banned local governments
and school districts
from imposing
their own mask mandates
and even said he opposed
vaccine mandates in hospitals.
And he also does
that Trump thing
where he says a line
that the crowd loves,
but, when you think about it,
it just doesn't make any sense.
-Politicians want to force you
to cover your face
as a way for them
to cover their own asses.
That's just the truth.
[ Applause ]
-What does he mean?
Has he been
reading bumper stickers
outside the Tampa AutoZone?
[ Laughter ]
I know it sounds
like an applause line,
because it's short and pithy
and people clap at the end,
but it doesn't actually
make any sense.
It's like when you're
at a Billy Joel concert
and everyone's singing along
with "We Didn't Start the Fire"
and then, you think about it
for a second and you're like,
"Wait, what,
'rock-and-roller cola wars,
I can't take it anymore'?
That was your breaking point,
the Cola wars?
[ Laughter ]
There was nothing else
happening in 1989
that served as a better breaking
point to end the song with?
You know what?
Let's just leave now
and beat the traffic.
Oh, look, there is no traffic.
I guess everybody left
after 'Space monkey Mafia'."
[ Laughter ]
With that said,
what a time to grow up!
I feel like my kids
experience a full verse
of "We Didn't Start the Fire"
events every week, now.
Meanwhile, when I was 16
and my dad would yell at me
to get my act together, the only
thing I could say to him was,
"Maybe your generation could've
have solved the cola wars, Dad!"
[ Laughter ]
By the way, can I just repeat?
For the millionth time,
no one likes wearing masks.
How do you think I feel,
trying to get a table
at a crowded restaurant
with the famous half
of my face covered?
So I try to say things that'll
help the maître d' recognize me.
"Uh, from the looks of it,
sir, we're full tonight."
Ah, well, maybe you should take
a closer look?
[ Laughter ]
And then they say, "We know
who you are, Mr. Meyers.
[ Laughter ]
We're fully booked."
How do you think I feel?!
But we need to protect ourselves
and we need
to protect each other.
Studies have repeatedly
shown that masks
cut down on transmission
and, the better the mask,
the more protection you get.
But, of course,
the best protection is
getting vaccinated.
We need a layered approach --
vaccines, masks, ventilation.
I don't know why right-wingers
get so mad about this.
I mean, complex problems
require complex solutions.
They don't want to hear that,
which is why they've spent
the entirety of the pandemic
lining up behind a guy
who once asked
his medical advisors
if we could just give people
a flu shot
to cure them of coronavirus,
a question so dumb,
it was immediately shot down.
-You take a solid flu vaccine,
you don't think that would have
an impact, or much
of an impact, on corona?
-First of all,
what's a solid flu vaccine?
Does he think there are
[bleep] flu vaccines
or people out there looking
for a Kirkland Signature
vaccine?
[ Laughter ]
It's not liquor.
There isn't a top shelf flu shot
where they spell it
like it's French.
[ Laughter ]
That clip is like
a Trump Rosetta Stone.
It captures so much about him
in like ten seconds.
He thinks he found a shortcut
because he doesn't actually want
to solve the problem,
it's incredibly stupid,
and, instead of asking
his advisors in private,
he waits until he's on-camera,
thus forcing them to tell him
to his face in public,
at which point
he immediately backs down.
I'm surprised
he didn't start attributing
all his medical ideas
to a friend.
[ As Trump ]
Uh, a friend of mine
wanted to know
if, maybe,
you could cure the virus
by swallowing a battery?
A battery covered in Bengay?
Is that something?
[ Laughter ]
No? No? Okay.
I'll tell my stupid friend
it's a no.
[ Laughter ]
And, now, Trump is trying
to erase history,
first, by claiming the vaccine
rollout under his administration
was a success, when, in reality,
it was a disaster.
-I'm very proud of the vaccine.
I've taken the vaccine.
I'm very, very proud of it.
At the same time, some people
don't want to take it
and, you know,
when I was president,
you didn't have this problem
with people not wanting
to take it.
They don't take it
because they don't trust Biden
and they don't trust
the Biden administration.
When I was president,
you didn't have people
protesting the vaccine.
If you just think back,
everybody wanted to get it
and we were giving out
over a million shots a day.
We had that thing rockin'.
-You did not have it rockin',
Wolfman Jerk.
[ Laughter ]
The vaccine rollout,
when you were president,
was a disaster.
You repeatedly missed
your own stated goals,
doses were thrown away,
and people were lined up
for hours
on sidewalks and in cars.
And you were totally AWOL
because you were spending
all your time trying
to get the election overturned.
As people were lining up
for hours
for vaccines in the middle
of a brutal winter,
when thousands of people
were dying from COVID every day,
just as a reminder,
this is what Trump was doing.
-The president hasn't attended
a task force meeting
in five months,
even though they've had one held
just in the last week,
so if that gives you any idea.
We're actually told by sources
he's much more consumed
by the state of this election
and contesting the results
than he is with the pandemic
surging across the country.
-One of the president's
visitors today, Mike Lindell,
the founder of MyPillow,
was seen over here
at the White House
outside the West Wing.
A White House official
did tell me, Wolf,
that it is believed that
the president and Lindell met.
-A Washington Post photographer
got a close-up of the notes
that he was carrying with him
and, Jake,
when you zoom in on them,
you can see that he is talking
about the election.
Things like martial law
are mentioned.
-The guy from MyPillow
is carrying documents
and talking to President Trump,
presumably about declaring
martial law.
-That was in January,
when we could've used
some national leadership
on the vaccine rollout.
Instead, Trump was listening
to a pillow salesman
read off his list of ideas
for stealing the election.
[ As Lindell ]
Mr. President, there's
something you can do
in martial law
that I highly recommend.
[ As Trump ]
What do I do
with martial law, Mike?
[ As Lindell ]
Da...clare it!
[ Laughter ]
Nope. Didn't work.
[ Laughter continues ]
I forced it and it didn't work.
By the way, Lindell is still --
he's still fighting
that lonely fight.
He was on OAN the other day,
complaining about Fox News
and mispronouncing a bunch
of anchors' names,
but, otherwise, you know,
it seems like
things are going
pretty well for him.
-This is disgusting!
Dominion sues good old OAN,
heroes!
OANs are heroes!
Where's Fox?!
Newsmax.
They sue OAN and Newsmax.
Fox, you need to step it up
and help save our country!
I seen stuff
by Jan Bongino on there.
He goes, "I say
whatever I want on my show,"
and people were going after him.
Why don't you call
and interview me?
Sean Hannity told me once,
he said,
"Mike, I can say
anything I want on Fox,
as long as it's the truth."
Well, the truth is, Sean,
we had a Cyber Symposium.
And the truth is you're not
saying anything on your show.
Neither are you, Laura.
Trucker tried, a few times,
to talk about the 2020 election.
I give him some credit.
I thought that might be
a breakthrough.
It was a couple of weeks ago.
But none of them are talking!
What is Fox doing to you?
Are you guys so -- you're
so worried about your money,
all four of you?
You're so worried
about your money and your job?
-[ As Lindell ]
I tried to call Jim Bongino
and Drunker Carlson
and Sean Hamminy, and none
of them would take my call.
I called the Fox & Friends,
Steve Dooky and Brian Kalamine.
I even showed up
outside the studio,
screaming like a lunatic,
saying, "I want to talk
to Judge Judy Janeane Garofolo!"
[ Laughter ]
But even more galling
than Trump's claim
that he had the vaccine rocking
was his grotesque lie
that COVID was gone
by the time he left office,
which it obviously was not.
-Coronavirus is back.
If that ever happened to me,
where it came back, okay?
When I left,
it was virtually gone.
-He thinks our attention spans
are all as short as his.
We can remember January.
There were
over 180,000 COVID cases
on Trump's last full day
in office.
Those are public numbers.
We didn't have to sneak into the
National Institutes of Health,
hack into their
computer systems,
and smuggle the data out
in a roll of microfiche hidden
in a coffee can.
Second use of microfiche
this week.
Last time I said,
I'd love to hear
Nic Cage say it,
but, if it were a comedy,
I think it could work
with Owen Wilson, too.
[ As Wilson ]
Ah, jeez, I hid the microfiche
in my sock drawer.
Now, it's gone!
[ Laughter ]
I haven't done Owen in a while
because, at Impression Camp,
we're working
on some new people.
For example, my McConaughey
is getting better.
My instructor told me
it's not the best, but it's
[ As McConaughey ]
Alright, alright, alright.
And then, get this --
the next morning,
he hung himself.
[ Laughter ]
My instructor hung himself.
[ Laughter continues ]
Anyway, it's one thing
for Fox to lie,
which they do all the time.
It's another to try
to rewrite history
in such a grotesquely
Orwellian fashion.
Like you can't just
let Trump come on
and say COVID had magically
disappeared by the time he left,
when 400,000 Americans had died.
You can't just "Men in Black" us
into forgetting about that,
although, I'm sure they
would try it, if they could.
Tucker Carlson always looks like
he just accidentally flashed
himself with the neuralyzer.
Rudy, meanwhile, looks like
he accidentally sat
on the neuralyzer.
[ As Giuliani ]
Oh, no! My butt's where
I keep all my memories.
How can we trust a network
whose hosts and guests
have a look of shock
on their faces,
like their dog
just made a phone call?
[ As Giuliani ]
Rusty, you can talk?
Who are you calling?
The police?
But how did you get
Sting's number?
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, see,
Shoemaker and this bit.
When Rudy hears "the police,"
he thinks the band.
[ Laughter ]
The current GOP is very much
the Trump GOP.
DeSantis is
a perfect example of that.
He's mimicking
Trump's COVID response.
As cases and hospitalizations
reach new records,
he's downplaying the threat
and refusing
basic mitigation efforts that
would help keep people safe.
It's exactly what Trump did
and, now, they're just
flagrantly lying about it
and trying to rewrite history.
Basically, their attitude is...
-"I can say
anything I want on Fox."
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.